I just thought we could have a little fun.
-Hmm.
-I'll bet...
ten TVs from our company.
-Ten TVs!
-That sounds great!
To be honest,
I've been wanting to get a Penasonic TV.
Has he been waiting for this opportunity?
Okay, Mr. Yamashita.
Then, what are you
prepared to bet in return?
Let me see...
If I lose, I'll give you the equivalent
to what the TVs are worth.
-What do you say?
-That's fine. It's a bet.
I proposed the bet to see
the caliber of the man.
I didn't expect him
to accept it so easily.
-That was very stupid.
-It's not a problem.
It's only ten TVs. It's peanuts
compared to what I already owe.
He was using
Kengan Association code words.
When someone offers
a product from "our company",
they mean shares in that company.
Shares?
And the number means the percentage.
Which means...
you've just accepted a high stakes gamble
betting ten percent of Penasonic's shares.
What? No!
Penasonic Corporation is
the biggest electronics company in Japan,
and he's betting
ten percent of their shares?
By the way, based on Penasonic
Corporation's current stock price,
the amount you'd pay
if you lose is about...
Two hundred and eighty billion yen.